elle qui continue place aux matchs des
idées confrontation de points de vue ce
soir entre roxane lundi est thomas
friands on va d'abord s'arrêter sur ce
1er mai agité notamment pour la cgt cela
fait quelques années que les défilés du
1er mai sont tendus on le sait un peu
mais le fait que le syndicat soit
violemment prise à partie un parti qui
défend les salariés depuis plus de 120
ans eh ben ça interroge ça pose question
donc on va ça on va en parler on va
s'interroger on va en discuter avec nos
invités dans un instant d'abord le
rappel des faits avec hugo l'aumônier un
1er mai en fin dé confiné qui devait
marquer le grand retour des syndicats
après un an de crise sanitaire
mais la situation dégénère en fin de
cortège à 18 heures des dizaines de
manifestants s'en prennent à des
véhicules de la cgt aux cris de cgt
collabos le service d'ordre du syndicat
intervient d'ilan quatre blessés graves
dans les rangs de la confédération
syndicale
on a notre cortège qui est attaquée et
donc ce que l'on veut faire nous c nous
replier tranquillement et ce sont les
barrages policiers qui nous en empêche
la réalité c'est celle là là dessus en
vingt ans de syndicalisme une situation
pareille je l' ai jamais connu moi
depuis samedi soir la cgt les partis de
gauche dénonce une attaque venue selon
eux de l'ultra-droite les insultes
homophobes ou le fait de traiter la cgt
du collabo c'est qu'elle paie lequel
calais quel renversement l'histoire
quelle attaque monstrueuse
non ça signe plutôt une extrême droite
décérébrés c'est elle qui est dangereuse
un conseil l'extrême droite dans ce pays
c'est elle qui finalement appel à
l'insurrection dans celle qui appelle à
la guerre civile
mais une autre piste est à l'étude celle
de militants d'ultragauche
une hypothèse tout à fait crédible selon
ce spécialiste des mouvements sociaux et
c'est un courant qui historiquement a
toujours été profondément est totalement
anti syndicale opposés aux syndicats
considérant que les
les la cgt ou fo et les autres sont
constitués de ce qu'ils appellent des
collabos de classe et donc ils
considèrent que les syndicats sont non
pas les défenseurs de la classe ouvrière
mais les ennemis de la classe ouvrière
une enquête pour violences volontaires
et dégradations en réunion a été ouverte
par le parquet de paris
avec nous pour le match des idées ce
soir au crâne lundi bienvenue vous êtes
membre de la direction nationale de
génération vous êtes conseillère
municipale à beauvais vous êtes sur la
liste de karima delli aux régionales
dans les hauts de france c'est bien ça
thomas friands et également avec nous
bien venu vous êtes directeur général de
l'institut open diplomatie vous êtes
membre de la république en marche bien
tous les deux si on va un petit peu plus
loin que les condamnations qui pleuvent
depuis 48 heures s'en prendre à la cgt
et roxanne l'indicé sans prendre un
symbole non qu'est-ce que ça dit du
climat qui règne dans notre pays
ah c'est absolument terrible fin ces
images sont bien sûr intolérable mais
c'est vrai que voir les militant
syndical de la cgt traité 1 610 aussi
non sur le climat là malheureusement qui
existe aujourd'hui dans notre pays c'est
pas anodin d'aller s'en prendre à des
syndicalistes qui sont ceux qui se
battent justement pour défendre nos
conditions de travail qui se battent
pour aujourd'hui avoir de nouvelles
conquêtes mal en soi c'est une crise de
confiance une crise de légitimité je
vais me lâcher je dirais même passage
jacques ça va plus loin que ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui doit nous interroger
encore plus sur la politique de maintien
de l'ordre qui est aujourd'hui mis en
oeuvre par le gouvernement par le
ministre de l'intérieur et par le préfet
de police
je lis très gentiment très simplement
j'ai manifesté à beauvais samedi dans
toute convivialité tout s'est très bien
passé et je constate quand même qu'année
après année nous avons des
manifestations qui ont toujours été des
manifestations pacifiques qui finissent
maintenant dans les gaz lacrymogènes
avec des images absolument terribles et
tout ça c'est aussi lié à la politique
aujourd'hui de 25 gardes du gouvernement
et du préfet de police qui monsieur
l'allemand qui aujourd'hui assume
d'aller aussi envoyer les policiers dans
la confrontation face à des militants
qui sont aussi pour beaucoup des
militants pacifistes
ce qui est terrible c'est que nous avons
besoin du service d'ordre de la cgt et
des slogans je crois que des policiers
ont été blessés mais bien si
échauffourée avec mais bien sûr des
policiers ont été blessés des militants
étaient blessés et finalement le service
d'ordre de la cgt est précieux parce
qu'il est celui qui nous protège quand
nous avons en effet des comportements
intolérables qu'ils peuvent être tenus
lors des manifestations j'observe que
les manifestations rassemblent de moins
en moins de monde mais qu'elles sont de
plus en plus violentes donc elle se
transforme et ça c'est marlène schiappa
qui l'a dit ce matin sur france info
c'est oui je rejoins ce que roxanne
lundi à évoquer à l'instant c'est
extrêmement grave et je dirais même plus
que ça moi ça me fait peur en fait parce
qu'on aborde une phase électorale où le
débat public a besoin de se dérouler le
droit de manifester fait pleinement
partie de notre constitution il fait
pleinement partie des droits civiques
qui permettent d'exprimer une forme
d'opinion politique et il est terrifiant
de voir que alors j'ai pas tout à fait
la même analyse des causes que que
roxana il est indispensable que une
politique de maintien de l'ordre
permettre le bon déroulement droit de
manifester c'est absolument aucun doute
là dessus il est absolument
indispensable aussi que les manifestants
puissent se doter d'un service de
maintien de l'ordre
kiki qui permettent le bon déroulement
des choses en l'occurrence il me semble
que les faits
qui sont très chauds sont très floues
pour les mieux informés d'entre nous qui
lisent le monde on voit que c'est un
groupe d'individus indistinct dont
certains se revendique des gilets jaunes
qui ont commis ces violences
christophe danse est un sujet du go
lemonnier dit que c'est l'extrême gauche
voilà en partie en partie contre la cgt
en partie contre les forces de l'anp de
moi ce que je ne suis pas ni un expert
des services de maintien de l'ordre
et encore moins un journaliste qui a
enquêté sur le sujet donc je
m'exprimerai pas sur les causes exactes
de cette de cette forme de violence là
en revanche ce qui m'inquiète
profondément c'est que à n'en pas douter
on peut pas avoir une élection
présidentielle et encore moins des
élections régionales qui se déroulent
dans un tel climat de violence et de
violences en particulier vers les forces
sociales parce qu'on le sait c'est ça
qui intéresse crises pandémiques net une
crise terrible pour l'emploi une crise
terrible pour l'économie
elle sera on sera nécessairement après
dans une phase de transition écologique
qui nécessite le dialogue social pour
accompagner pour fluidifier la
transition et on peut pas avoir comme ça
la cgt même si elle a perdu de sa
superbe
aux élections professionnelles on ne
peut pas avoir comme ça une forme de
violence et les élections les résultats
aux élections professionnelles de la
légitimité syndicale n'expliquerons
jamais une forme de violence ni vers les
forces de l'ordre ni vers l'est la cgt
donc moi je ne comprends pas cette forme
de violence il me semble que unanimement
quelles que soient les forces politiques
qui qui discutent de ce sujet il faut
condamner sans aucune réserve
l'état de la nation peut-être quand même
aller un peu plus loin il faut essayer
de savoir pourquoi les hommes et femmes
s'entraînent si violemment
benjamin marquis était sur place qui est
de la cgt à 10 ans 20 ans de
syndicalisme une situation pareille
je ne les ai jamais connu alors encore
une fois au delà des condamnations il
faut peut-être chercher les causes pour
pour les combattre mais parfaitement les
propos de madame schiappa je les trouve
aussi assez scandaleux parce
qu'aujourd'hui si nous sommes aussi de
moins en moins nombreux à être
manifestation c'est parce que désormais
lorsque nous allons manifestation eh
bien il n'est pas il n'est pas rare de
repartir avec les yeux rouges après sept
prix du gaz lacrymogène dans les yeux
alors que le 1er mai c'est une
manifestation où on vient avec ses
enfants
on vient avec ses petits enfants c'était
un brin de muguet à la main ce travail
là nos conquêtes sociales tout
simplement et donc ce qui est terrible
c'est que oui la politique de maintien
de l'ordre est aussi en jeu parce que
cette politique de maintien de l'ordre
doit permettre à tous les manifestants
de venir dans un cadre apaisé rassurant
manifester en toute convivialité
alors ces images elles sont terribles
mais il faut aussi et je lance vraiment
un vrai signal d' alerte aussi
s'interroger sur le discours qu'on a je
dis on je des plantes bien sur la cgt
mais les discours qu'ils sont tenus par
des responsables politiques sur les
syndicats qui alimente aussi un discours
anti syndicale qui fait que les
syndicalistes sont vus par certains
comme étant responsable de tous les maux
c'est scandaleux
heureusement qu'on a la cgt heureusement
qu'on a ces syndicats qui se mobilisent
qu'ils étaient dans la rue contre les
ordonnances pénicaud qui ont encore
attaqué nos droits nous droits sociaux
heureusement que nos syndicats soleure
au quotidien pour lutter contre
l'explosion des burn out par exemple les
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
qui n'ont pas toujours été très simple
dans un contexte de co visant à mettre
en place et qui sont finalement cette
vigie est en tout cas sur roulettes
reconquête sociale si si précieux et
essentiel je voudrais qu'on reparle à
présent d'un autre sujet un sujet très
politique et on en a parlé dans le débat
juste avant votre arrivée c'est cette
alliance en paca qui fait trembler la
droite renaud muselier a perdu
l'investiture et l'air après avoir reçu
le soutien de la république en marche
depuis il est accusé de tous les maux il
risque même l'exclusion de son parti une
décision devrait être prise demain matin
le président sortant ni toute trahison
et d'y combattre le rassemblement
national il promet d'ailleurs de ne pas
intégrer de ministres de parlementaires
dans sa liste avant de vous demander ce
que vous en pensez on va accueillir dans
ce match philippe dominati bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur de paris
apparenté au groupe l air tout est dans
le mot apparentés vous êtes quand même
relativement libre de votre parole ce
soit vous le condamnez vous renaud
muselier
non je ne condamne pas dans la mesure où
on pourrait peut-être même le féliciter
parce que celui qui fracturent la
majorité présidentielle c'est lui c'est
pas lui qui monte dans les bagages de la
majorité présidentielle celle inverse
c'est un président sortant qui a un
bilan et qui essaye de rassembler le
plus large possible
donc je ne comprends pas les mois je
dirais de certains membres de ma famille
politique dans la mesure où ce qui
compte c'est l'efficacité
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent ils veulent
faire passer de cette région auprès du
rassemblement national
je rappelle que dans cette région il ya
six ans ce n'est que le retrait de la
liste socialiste de monsieur castetner
qui avait permis à monsieur estrosi de
l'emporter c'est ça la réalité alors les
alliances ce type elles ont déjà eu lieu
monsieur muselier risque l'expulsion
mais madame pécresse président de région
a quitté l'ère monsieur xavier bertrand
président de région a déjà quitté l air
si c'est une nécessité pour que cette
région reste dirigée par la droite est
bien l r aka l'exclure mais à la manière
dont l air à gérer les dernières
municipales à marseille à la manière
dont les municipales ont été gérés à
lyon où une alliance entre monsieur
wauquiez
monsieur collomb entre les deux tours a
eu lieu en dernière minute on cherche
l'efficacité mais cette efficacité
le président de région essaye de la
trouvait manifestement philippe de
benetti ne pas réagir ne pas sanctionner
renaud muselier est ce que c'est pas
tuer le parti ait l'air est ce que ce
n'est pas admettre que les frontières
entre les deux parties sont tellement
poreuses que finalement c'est la même
chose
non elles sont pas poreuse pour moi le
gouvernement je suis dans l'opposition
nationale au parlement et pour moi ce
n'est pas la même chose par contre je
fais une distinction entre l'efficacité
lorsqu'il ya quelqu'un qui est proche de
moi
politiquement c'est à dire de la droite
modérée qui a toujours été un candidat
de droite comme monsieur estrosi
d'ailleurs pourquoi vouloir à tout prix
se déchire et vous comprenez il ya un
mois heller se déchaînaient face à
xavier bertrand
bon ils ont le droit mais qu'ils
proposent quelque chose aujourd'hui
eychenne contre monsieur muselier dites
moi quel est le candidat qui prépare les
présidentielles et l'air avec le soutien
de cette formation politique en dehors
de repousser à chaque fois le débat on
veut repousser le fait de savoir s'il ya
des primaires au pas de primaire on veut
mettre la poussière sous le tapis
en réalité on ferait mieux de travailler
sur un programme qui nous rassemble
plutôt que sur des divisions qui mois
après mois s'accumulent entre les
différents ténors de cette formation
politique
philippe dominati ce que vous diriez
qu'il y a deux droites irréconciliables
au sein du parti l air que c'est un
parti fracturée oui elle est fracturée
parce qu'il manque un leader qui est
soit capable de rassembler et de faire
la synthèse comme avait su le faire les
présidents de droite lorsque la droite
est au pouvoir c'est à dire un parti
avec une morale morale gouvernementale
et là on voit très bien que en réalité
les critiques qui sont faites ne peut
aboutir qu'à une seule chose c'est faire
basculer cette région pour le
rassemblement national
si c'est le but de ces divisions c'est
regrettable
je ne sais pas si c'est la bonne
tactique employée par monsieur muselier
de faire une alliance dès le premier
tour mais il faut se poser la question
quelle est l'attitude de l air ou second
tour est ce que si on se trouve face à
nos rassemblements nationale et
messieurs muselier on accepterait cette
alliance
alors je pense que c'est une question de
transparence et de clarté vis-à-vis des
électeurs de le faire à un peu à l'avant
plutôt que de le faire entre les deux
tours comme sollicités tout à l'heure à
lyon aux municipales ou en l'espace
d'une semaine
on essaye de raccommoder de trouver une
coédition qui ne peut pas fonctionner
parce qu'il faut être transparent
vis-à-vis des électeurs mais finalement
ça m'emballe pas le set ce flou qui
consiste à dire régionalement
on pense qu'il vaut mieux faire c'est à
dire ans mais il faut aussi choisir
l'adversaire ou l'allié de demain je
pense que cette alliance peut
fonctionner comme elle peut fonctionner
dans d'autres régions
madame pécresse c'est bien
on savait que le modem qui fait partie
de la majorité présidentielle vous savez
comme moi que les élus du modem qui font
partie de la majorité régionale
on considérait que madame pécresse elle
un bilan plutôt positif et donc ils font
une alliance pourquoi l heure ne
condamne pas lents dans ces conditions
il ya deux poids deux mesures et moi ce
qui me gêne par contre c'est une
alliance faite avec celui qui aurait été
jambes tuellement le premier ministe
marine le pen aux dernières
présidentielles monsieur dupont-aignan a
eu lieu en france
en réalité à l'eire n'a plus de
direction depuis quelques temps ce jus
aux municipales
ça se voit en régionale ce qui se passe
en paca ce n'est pas une surprise c'est
quelque chose qui était prévisible
il n'y a pas eu de travail de fait il
n'y a pas eu d'explication de pédagogie
et surtout de solutions concrètes
en dehors de dire il faut charger sabre
au clair drapeaux au vent et mourir pour
la bonne cause mourir politiquement pour
la bonne cause le message que vous
envoyer ce soir est très fort rester
avec nous philippe dominati on va
continuer d'en discuter en plateau si
vous le voulez bien thomas friands c'est
sévère mais c'est le constat de philippe
dominati pas de vraie direction au sein
de l'ess c'est ça qui explique la
situation d'aujourd'hui
ça fait longtemps que ça l'expliquent c1
le ce parti est devenu un parti canard
sans tête depuis longtemps depuis que
l'iso été incapables de se mettre
d'accord sur les résultats de la
primaire
une fois deux fois
sur la façon dont il fallait gérer la
sphère fillon une fois deux fois enfin
bref c'est la droite du lol aujourd'hui
les républicains c'est à dire que on a
examiné bertrand qui a été élu sur un
front républicain qui doit tout à ce que
la gauche lui a légué pour battre marine
le pen et qui a le culot de se présenter
aux élections régionales en même temps
qui veut se présenter aux élections
présidentielles en disant je veux
rassembler plage possible et quand son
voisin du sud rassemble ils nous
crachent au visage
dans la région paca c'est la même chose
je rappelle juste un fait qui semble
échapper à de nombreux commentateurs le
candidat du front du rassemblement
international dans cette région qui sait
thierry mariani c'est qu'ils tiraient
marien d'anciens élèves c'est un ancien
républicain et qu'ils seront meilleurs
soutiens eric ciotti qui affiche aux
yeux de tous que il n'y a absolument
aucune différence entre les républicains
et leur abondance nationale si c'était
l'art de gouverner
sachant que le candidat du rassemblement
national est un ancien ministre
heller qui a gouverné je m'excuse mais
là je vois plus du tout la différence
donc épargnons nous c'est faux débat on
a un rassemblement qui est qui a
vocation à faire tenir cette région qui
est extrêmement fragilisée par la crise
du corona virus sur un socle de valeurs
qui ce qui s'est bâti et qui s'est bâtie
aussi dans l'histoire de cette région
déjà extrêmement exposées aux risques
d'extrême droite comme cela a été
rappelé l instant par un désistement des
les dernières élections régionales pour
favoriser un barrage au front national
je pense que cette droite du lol elle a
fait son temps elle est parfaitement
incohérentes si on prend chaque région
on voit la difficulté est absolument
identique valérie pécresse qui a eu un
morceau de sa liste qui vient la
majorité présidentielle xavier bertrand
qui fera tout pour rassembler et qui
d'ailleurs rappelle constamment
rassemblement
etc etc on n'a pas de direction morale
et ça fait très longtemps peut-être la
seule nuance que j'aurais à porter parce
qu'il vient d'être dit c'est que c'est
pas un leader qu'il faut à ce parti ça
fait très longtemps qu'il en a pas c'est
des idées et des idées qui font commun
qui font sens on a toujours observé
depuis le traité de maastricht et ça
s'est accentué avec le traité de
lisbonne une droite du oui une droite
dit non sur les questions européennes et
à la veille de la présidence française
de l'union européenne bien sûr qu'on
n'aura jamais un michel barnier dans la
même pièce car laurent wauquiez je
rappelle qu'ils étaient candidats l'un
contre l'autre aux dernières élections
régionales pour la région auvergne
rhône-alpes et ils ont ils ont tous les
deux des ambitions présidentielles
donc arrêtons ces faux débat enfin lise
grande clarification mais enfin nicolas
sarkozy l'a perdu deux fois quand même
il a perdu l'élection présidentielle et
puis après il a perdu la vie après il a
perdu l'élection primaire pour revenir à
l'élection présidentielle contre son
ancien pro ministre donc c'est amusant
mais cette grande clarification c'est la
fin des grandes compromission il est
temps allons d'avant je sais pas si
c'est amusant roxane lundi non mais si
c'est presque amusant parce que oui
aujourd'hui on a un coup de com non tout
comme qui est fait de la part des
républicains je l'entends aujourd'hui
elle rer et lr c'est quand même bonnet
blanc et blanc bonnet dans les
politiques qui sont mises en oeuvre
quelles différences majeures y at il eu
ces derniers temps entre la politique
appliquée par le gouvernement et le
président de la république et celle que
nous aurions eu de la part de n'importe
quel dirigeant de l'est républicain
honnêtement je mets au défi quiconque de
venir nous les expliquer et très
concrètement c'est vrai qu'à une forme
d'hypocrisie va aux élections
municipales il ya eu dans presque toutes
les villes de france des aliments
centrale rm et à l'air dans ma ville à
beauvais dès le premier tour
la république en marche et les
républicains étaient unis et ça a été
comme ça donc énormément demandé trois
ans de la part de l air quelques
d'intérêt mais c'est un coup de com pour
essayer de se dissocier à un an de la
présidentielle du président de la
république parce qu'aujourd'hui oui l
air a besoin de faire un peu
d'identitaires et d'expliquer qu'il ne
sont pas exactement la même chose qu'eux
rm et qu'ils auraient mené des
politiques différentes je donne un
exemple sur monsieur bertrand par
exemple mais bien menée à ce qui est
annoncé mais monsieur bertrand
aujourd'hui lance la campagne
alors il se dit candidat à la
présidentielle pour la droite
voilà avec les républicains mais
aujourd'hui tous les piliers de la
majorité présidentielle était à ses
côtés
il était avec la maire d'amiens qui
était soutenu par la république en
marche qui aujourd'hui la tête de liste
le pied la majorité présentielle c'est
le président la république il n'est pas
candidat aux côtés xavier bertrand vous
faites une caricature qui est maintenant
la junte parce que c'est ce que je sois
pas tant celle pied on peut aussi parce
qu'il ya toujours un collectif vous avez
de nuancer il est important de la voir
et quand on voit la politique de santé
de xavier bertrand ministre de la santé
qui applique la tarification à l'acte
qui met l'état de l'hôpital juif dans
l'état que l'on connaît et quand on voit
le ségur de la santé qui est une
revalorisation comparer investissements
dans l'hôpital une revalorisation de
tous les deux tout les bas salaires des
fonctions publiques du soin ne peut pas
faire des comparaisons de lits dont il
encore des fermetures de lits dans les
hôpitaux il faut bien besoin
c'est donc la même idéologiques et mise
en menant ces lamelles appliquer les
centres qui me semble pas parce qu'on
est là aussi il y en a aussi dans les
régions qui sont gouvernés par le parti
socialiste qui sont les alliés y en
avait six dans la région
comme vous l'avait dit dans le caddie
ségur c'est encore des discussions
qu'ils ont aussi mené à une impasse que
rendait au contraire il ya des quantités
de lait qui ont été réouverts en
réanimation n'est capacités qui ont été
doublés mais qui me semble qu'il faut
avoir un esprit fin je pense que c'est
ça qui fait un peu défaut
malheureusement à cette gauche qui n'a
pas réussi à se rassembler parce
qu'elles n'arrivent pas à trouver des
points de convergence
là on a des chances entre jeu le racing
à des agents on a des convergences
depuis 2010 est et depuis un peu avant
entre des progressistes qui viennent
d'une droite sociale libérale et des
progressistes et des idées progressistes
qui viennent du droit social démocrate
qui ne se retrouvent plus dans le
maelström de la gauche post
universaliste d'aujourd'hui est donc oui
ça vous ennuie un centre très fort en
france parce que vous en dites
votre vous parlez d'un centre très fort
est en même temps que vous théorisé très
clairement le fait qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une alliance avec la droite de l'est
républicain la réalité c'est que nous
nous voyons bien dans les politiques et
c'est très intéressant dans le débat
public il ya quelques années quand le
président de la république est arrivé
nous disait je suis ni droite ni gauche
qui croient encore aujourd'hui que le
président de la république est ni de
droite ni de gauche
il suffit de voir d'ailleurs les
sondages quel qu'il soit la prise d'eau
pignon la réalité c'est pour toutes ces
équipes dans la gestion d'un tirailleur
mental c'est un président de droite avec
un premier ministre de droite et une
majorité avec un gouvernement qui est un
gouvernement je me comprends pas parce
que quand on prend le le prologue tous
les to les toute la séquence depuis le
début de ce quinquennat que ça soit sur
l'hôpital
que ce soit sur la justice que ce soit
sur la santé que ça soit sur le climat
je veux dire on a on est alors on est
dans cette génération puisque vous êtes
sensible aux questions environnementales
on le savait très bien comme moi on a à
peu près le je pense le même âge on est
dans cette génération qui fait face au
concret de la transition écologique et
qui a fermé toutes les centrales à
charbon françaises qui a fait une loi de
programmation l'énergie qui nous permet
de voir à long terme pour développer un
mix énergétique qui dépasse le nucléaire
qui a fermé notre dame des landes
et c est à dire on peut faire des
caricatures à longvic mais à un moment
donné il ya des écolos qui ont pascal
canfin pascal durand il ya des écolos
par quantités considérables qui ont
rejoint par barrera pompidou qui ont
rejoint ce gouvernement qui travaillent
au sein de ce gouvernement qui font
avancer la principale loi climat à
l'échelle européenne qui va être votée
par le parlement
est-ce qui est ce qu'elle ne soulève pas
un certain nombre d'oppositions
ben je sais pas ce que marie mercier
maire la prochaine c'est le 9 sept le
climat avec borloo présent qui se
mobilisent en disant que justement elle
est assez ambitieux climat au parlement
européen n'a été voté à l'unanimité par
là commission environ
demande du parlement européen sous
l'égide de pascal canfin donc moi
j'aimerais bien mais il voyons les faits
avec un cachet ne tue avec les chefs
d'état qui ont quand même pris des
engagements qui étaient bien en dessous
de ce qui était demandé est proposée
même par le parlement alors on va parler
des hauts de france mais je vais quand
même saisir de ce silence
ça m'a fait réagir philippe dominati si
vous le souhaitez soit vous laissez
tranquille philippe dominati
oui je voudrais revenir sur mon
introduction parce que j'entends les
commentaires
encore une fois c'est une politique
menée par la droite en est à mon paca et
ce qui ravit la candidature et le projet
de bruno vigier de renaud muselier
ce sont des alliés c'est pas l'un vers
ce qui est en train de se produire
en réalité il ya une dynamique était
fait laissez-les dynamics et
l'élargissement le rassemblement du plus
grand nombre
c'est ça qui compte lorsqu'il y aura des
gens de droite de la droite dont je fais
parti dont je me posais la politique du
gouvernement au parlement qui va
rassembler le plus possible je suis
toujours favorable à cette disposition
parce que c'est le seul moyen pour le
pays de changer de politique en évitant
d'une part marine le pen et d'autre part
la continuité d'un pouvoir qui est un
pouvoir venant quand même à l'origine
essentiellement par l'assemblée
nationale du parti socialiste
alors peut-être que vous allez rester
avec nous parce que le troisième
chapitre peut vous intéresser aussi on
va on va parler des hauts de france
philippe dominati vous avez tant rester
avec nous rtl a publié un sondage bv
avec orange ce matin sondage assez
intéressant voilà ce qu'on peut en
retenir en tout cas voilà ce que moi
j'en ai retenu
xavier bertrand arriverait en tête avec
33% des intentions de vote
mais attention suivi de très près
regardé par sébastien chenu qui
obtiendrait lui 31% des intentions de
vote la gauche rassemblée derrière
karima delli fret à 17% des intentions
de vote et le candidat en marche
laurent pietra chef qui serait à peine à
10% pour gagner xavier bertrand aurait a
priori mathématiquement besoin d'une
alliance avec la république en marche au
second tour pas question répond le
président sortant écouter même projet
même liste premier et deuxième tours
donc même pas où se profile un premier
drop a eu dans son plan d'arrangement
pas de confusion
est ce qu'ils vont proposer ça ne
risquait pas un
il connaissait par avance la réponse non
deuxièmement demandé le manuel macron
mais je pense que ça l'arrangerait bien
que je perde
alors si on suit votre raisonnement
philippe dominati peut-être un mot
là-dessus il a tort alors ah non pas du
tout il fait exactement la même chose
que mu juillet c'est à dire il fait
preuve de clarté en définissant ses
listes avec des gens qui veulent adhérer
à un projet pour sa région et il dit il
y aura pas dans deux d'accord d'état
major entre les deux tours en semaine on
voit pas dire aux électeurs
alala nous sommes les meilleurs et puis
on va fusionner entre les deux tours il
est collé ce plaisir qu'il a des projets
pardon il ya un risque de laisser gagner
le rassemblement national alors il prend
son risque ils le disent très bien dit
d'ailleurs que l'intéressé j'avais
resserre pour la présidentielle c'est
peut-être de lui donner rendez vous ici
prends tu y prends son risque mais en
tout cas il veut une équipe cohérente à
sociétaux et pas faire des arrangements
de dernière minute entre les deux tours
c'est ce que faire un homme janvier en
bas car à ma connaissance c'est ce que
fait madame pécresse en prenant le
modèle tout de suite son service deux
mois ou trois mois pour être cohérents
sur le sur la majorité qu'on propose au
conseil régional
sur ce plan-là ya une cohérence alors
roxane lundi mais j'entends bien ce qui
est dit mais ça n'est pas la réalité
concrète de ce qui est en train de se
passer et de ce qui se passe dans les
autres ans je le disais à la tête de
liste dans la somme de monsieur bertrand
et avait le soutien de la république en
marche à l'élection municipale puisque
c'est il s'agit de la mer damien qui
était parfaitement soutenu par le
président de la république qui est même
venu à amiens lui apporter son soutien
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
encore de la communication qui est en
train d'être fait et moi je le dis
d'autant plus que je suis une femme de
gauche et écologistes et que donc
toute la gauche et les écologistes à la
dernière élection fait un choix qui
était un choix douloureux et responsable
celui de se retirer pour à tout prix
tout faire pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite parce qu'il était hors
de question bien sûr est là vous avez
choisi de miser db oui hélas ça ne prend
pas ça marche ça ne semble pas prôner à
il ya plusieurs choses que nous montre
ce sondage donc il ya les chiffres bruts
mais ce que nous montre ce sondage aussi
c'est que nous sommes à un mois et demi
de l'élection régionale que nous avons
encore besoin de d'entrer dans un débat
politique et débat démocratique autour
de ce que j'ai rattrapé le retard la de
17 points à plus de 3 points voudront le
mois et demi qui vient oui je vais vous
le dire pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que nous avons une tête de liste
qui est une femme formidable et qui
gagnera à être connu chaque fois il ya
plein de gens formidables qui se
présentent mais même nom mais ce que
montre aussi le sondage c'est que nous
avons une grande partie des citoyennes
et des citoyens qui se sont pas encore
intéressés à ces élections pour la
simple et bonne raison que vous avez vu
ce qu'on a vu ces dernières semaines
avec tout un tout un micmac sur le
report ou non le maintien ou non des
élections
donc là on entre seulement dans la phase
où on commence à s'intéresser à ces
élections dont on ne savait même pas il
ya quelques semaines encore qu'elle
pourrait se tenir en juin prochain que
vous gardez de quoi non seulement nous
gardons espoir mais je vous le dis nous
allons entrer en campagne
nous entrons en campagne c'est
maintenant que les choses vont se jouer
avec une liste d'union
parce qu'il est hors de question que
nous revenions sur le même schéma que
nous avions eu à la dernière élection
parce que ça nous a énormément coûté et
nous avons un président de région qui ne
s'est pas montré à la hauteur mais ça
arrive
retirez votre liste ou pas mais la
question là on fait de la politique
fiscale y ont la peau l'annoncions
vraiment quand même mais la réalité
c'est que aujourd'hui le président de
région a une responsabilité qui est
celle d'aller se battre pour défendre ce
mandat nous avons une responsabilité la
gauche et l'écologie c'est de proposer
une alternative crédible
il est hors de question que nous ayons
encore ce duo duel qui nous est annoncé
entre la droite et l'extrême droite
comme nous l'avons eue à la
présidentielle donc nous nous sommes
unis nous allons mener une belle et
grande campagne avec karima delli qui
est une personne je le dis formidable
mais qui est président de la commission
transports au parlement européen qui est
une femme de dossiers qui connaît son
territoire qui connaît ses dossiers et
nous allons aller à les convaincre
dans les semaines qui viennent et je le
dis à tous les électeurs de gauche et
écologistes nous ne pouvons pas et nous
ne devons pas revenir sur la même
situation qu'à la dernière élection pour
la simple et bonne raison que le
président de région ne s'est pas montré
à la hauteur de la confiance qui lui
tomba friands il nous reste une mine et
oui il nous reste six minutes pour dire
faire mode dès qu'une personne dit
refuse de faire la politique fiction à
partir de résultats chiffrés je sais
déjà que c'est une fiction politique ce
qui va nous est racontée est là ce que
j'observe c'est que la seule le seul
enseignement qu'on peut tirer au delà
les extrapolations du score potentiel de
karima delli que je respecte par
ailleurs pour ses travaux au parlement
européen et je pense qu'elle ferait bien
de continuer ses travaux à cette échelle
qui sont essentiels pour le green deal
et le plan de relance rendent bien
on a le seul enseignement qu'on peut
tirer de ce sondage c'est que le front
national comme dans le sud comme dans la
région paca est aux portes du pouvoir
par tous et que à partir du moment où on
se gargarise de commentaires et de
comparaison qui n'ont ni queue ni tête
entre xavier bertrand et renaud muselier
qui n'ont pas du tout la même histoire
politique et non pas été élu dans les
mêmes conditions qui n'ont pas les mêmes
ambitions qui n'ont pas la même à chaque
fois qu'on con con qu'on refuse de rien
regardez la réalité est là on la prend
en face et la réalité c'est que on a
besoin de pouvoir arrêter une bonne fois
pour toutes par des campagnes qui font
effet et des résultats sur sur le
terrain la progression du rassemblement
national
il me semble que nationalement la fin
vous aurez eu à la conclusion merci
infiniment à tous les trois merci
philippe dominati lieu d'être
avec nous c'était pas prévu merci
beaucoup à tous les deux très vite fin
de cette émission se retrouvent demain à
18h30 attention et à 22h30 dans un
instant auditions publiques l'invité ce
soir philippe marc martinez et quimper
général de la cgt et puis demain bonjour
chez vous dès 7h30 au rayonnement de
chimie recevra notamment famille roussel
cet international du parti communiste je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
public sénat